Let's actually use the framework on a real website.
Here's a mock up for a portfolio site that you can use.
There's a link in the instructor notes.
Think about what you learned last lesson about approaching the process of
going from design to an actual website.
But instead of creating new classes and styles from scratch,
you should use the classes that your new framework supports.
I've gone ahead and drawn some boxes around different elements in the mock up.
These boxes correspond with the rows and columns from the framework.
Which classes correspond with the boxes in the mock up?
Which class would you use for the red box at the top, the blue box at the top,
the red box at the bottom, and the blue box at the bottom?
Type your answers in here.